so bad for a man to be sexually active
as much as a woman sexually active and
have the freedom to be sexually active
and not only that but you see really it
isn't it isn't that's right
because i'm not saying you're not
allowed to be sexually active i'm just
saying you can't be sexually active with
me i hate what you're saying i hit like
okay that's not what you want to work
but i think like
what you just said was the total
reversal of what we know is true like
it's okay for you guys to be hosed but
as soon as a woman has slept around
yeah it's because men and women are
different it's a double standard no it's
definitely that's what i'm saying but
you said it like in terms of what
because if if if your girlfriend's man
slept around you're not going to be like
it's all right darling like it's me no
i'm not right so there we go so let's
not make it out like i was i was brought
up by a man i was raised by my dad so i
was instilled early into me that what
what we think of women who [ __ ] around
because after my mom passed away all my
dad did was [ __ ] around
so i soon got to see how women that
[ __ ] up got treated so
i knew that from the start and i
wouldn't be happy for my daughters to
sleep around that is what's instilled in
me all right it's like this
digger
a male gold digger yeah is looked at
worse than a female gold digger as in
that show what was that show called 100
the um
the thing that girls do every single day
on this earth he was
no no no i'm serious like there are
entire industries built on women
scamming men online because one in three
men under the age of 30 hasn't done sex
in the past year or is a virgin one in
three men
yeah so there are entire industries
built off of women doing webcam and that
sort of thing
getting money and extracting money off
of men that's how andrew tate made his
money that's why he's a
multi-multi-millionaire and nobody bats
and eye nobody cares when it's a guy and
they say you should have known better
but with the women they get a whole
goddamn documentary yeah but they're
they're getting something out of it it's
a transaction all right let me ask you
something no no because they'll sell him
the dream that's what they do and like
andrew tate like breaks this down where
they will literally
convince these guys that one day they're
going to meet one day they're going to
sleep together one day one day one day
and like this happens every day no one
cares maybe the women are watching
disney
maybe maybe maybe the girls in the
tinder swindler should stop watching
disney absolutely
[Laughter]
but i'm saying people did fundraisers
they were raising money for these women
yeah but to me i'm like that was your
own damn fault why on earth would anyone
donate to that and that's what i would
say to the guys too but for the men
they do it yeah like they don't nobody
cares the women people care
when your heart is hungry you eat so i
want to ask you something ladies and
gentlemen what how would you not feel if
males exploited women the way how women
exploit males in the porn industry in
terms of this
all right so we're getting there now so
let's get there so we know that this man
at home is sitting down lonely he has no
sex he hasn't he's has no female
interaction but you're using that as
your tool to get money out of him okay
is that not exploitation i've i i only
watch
from with men i don't
yeah i only watched corn with them
and made and female so how are we
exploiting because no i'm saying in
terms of like only fans in terms of like
yeah
um um chat obey i'm talking about all
these websites where they have girls
it's a it's a website where girls sit
down in front of the cam and they're
like you're right i'm lonely guy four
five six yeah send me send me some dough
i'll show you my feet
like i'm your best friend i'm saying
this exploitation happens on what do you
mean it's exploitation is it just that
right it's dangerous
is it exploitation or is it just an
exchange of services
can you hear that right okay so you
could argue that's what the tinder
swindler did
yes
so i can't comment but he did get taken
to court right didn't he actually like
con them which is slightly different
yeah they just made his career
it's i would say slightly different
because he's met these individuals in
person he's built a rapport with them
he's he's actually thought allowed them
to think that they are getting to know
him as a person like if i was to meet
anybody
if we
there were some individuals that thought
they were engaged to this man they they
physically been together okay okay but
so so the same way like the way you're
talking is literally how andrew tate
describes how the women need to talk to
the men
like i'm telling you word for word
basically and so just like i think it's
delusional of those men
to think that a woman like that is gonna
take them seriously i think it's a
delusional of those women 100 average
average looking girls to think that a
multi-millionaire is going to take you
seriously is there not a difference when
there's a
um web screen
put in the way because the chats that we
were talking about that's kind of you're
paying for something virtually yeah as
opposed to something with the tinder
swindler where that's in person you're
meeting these people and building no i'm
that can i can i give you a stat so um
the results revealed that 23 of women
have engaged in a foodie foodie call on
an occasional basis with a number of
them believing it was socially
acceptable the second study analyzed 357
female participants and further
discovered that 33 of women would go on
a date purely for a free meal right so
this happens like every day face to face
so you you like when you said you'll
make him wait
he there's nothing stopping you from
actually having sex with him on day one
well it comes down to my own values i
know when whenever you you're ready
obviously
after a couple more dates after i've
spent my money on you after i often wait
hold on because
you potentially after the three months
could say you know what i actually don't
like you
but i've already invested in you for
three months well isn't that dating
for for for you that's dating for me
that's an expense but why are you
assuming that it's an expense because
you know what i want that the mail is
paying no no you know what i want what
do you want
what does every man want from a woman
that he's going in there
no no i'm not saying that she's not
saying that you have to just give it up
he's talking about there's two different
types of girls right there's a type of
girl that makes you wait because it's
genuine and there's a girl that makes
you wait because she bit she's been ran
through and she's afraid of getting ran
through again and it's just completely
different to guys i think both are
justified to make somebody wait i think
it could be justified to a female
perspective but that's not how men view
it because they value chastity
they value purity and so it's like
you're you're the product right and it's
like you're upping the price that they
have to pay
to get the product without adding any
extra value
it's like you're a lower value you might
have learned a few tricks
it's all about choice though isn't it
it's as simple as that you have a choice
if you don't want to stay with someone
who is a hoe go life you do exactly have
fun yeah but you're the is the deception
so you're saying i should be able to
deceive and you have the choice whether
or not you want to be deceived or not
doesn't it doesn't mean that the
deceiver is right to deceive what is
that
men deceive every diet exactly but does
it make it right that they deceive
everything that's not that's not no it
doesn't make it wise
but a very small percentage of men even
have the option to deceive women again
one in three men under 30 either haven't
had sex in the past year
or are virgins
so that's what i'm saying the reason
women like say phrases like that is
because we're all sleeping with the same
guys it's a very small percentage of men
that can even get girls